en tout cas on est très très heureux
aujourd'hui parce qu'on reçoit trois
personnes qu'on aime beaucoup alors
arnaud ducret c'est la famille
le premier thème c'est j'ai envie de
vous dire le câlin le bien-être il ya
une bonne nouvelle dans la 1e ou la 2e
ou une mauvaise nouvelle dans l'ain ou à
deux c'est à dire quelqu'un qui se fera
faire un vrai qu'à l'un et l'autre qui
va se prendre un cas un peu différente
je ne sais absolument pas je vous le
jure ce cadre les cabines
c'est à vous de choisir si c'est ce que
vous voulez à ça je vous garantis que je
ne sais rien je ne sais pas qui a donc
d'un côté vous allez avoir un vrai beau
qu'à l'art qui devrait vous plaire
de l'autre j'ai peur que ça soit un peu
transpirant le câlin pour l'instant j'ai
peur que ce soit ça ok j'ai choisi alors
voilà donc
je regarde la taille des cabines sauna
ne vous lancez pas eu deux donc vous
choisissez la deux nous allons aller
tous les deux devant puisque de toute
façon quand vous vous en prenez une au
jeu prend automatiquement le monde
ouais d'accord il a choisi la deux d'un
côté il y a le vrai qu'à l'un de l'autre
côté c'est top à la transpiration
mais merde au complet mais mon cadavre
je le crois
maintenant c'est la tarte soit elle et à
manger soit elle est dans la période
alors attention vous et ça tu veux qu'on
ouvre en même temps vous voulez laquelle
la 1 ou la 2g en fait ces terres que je
glisse mad men quoi en fait ça rires
c'est ce qui est de ce fabuleux dans ce
jeu c'est qu'on a réussi à trouver des
jeux où il n'y a rien à gagner on s'en
prend plein la corde c'est juste une
question d'être arrosé il a apporté pas
de là deux mois je te jure je te promets
et j'ai déjà pris et de l'eau si je
pouvais ne pas plutôt regarder le même
territoire garde attention on ouvre en
même temps
non non non alors là si tu veux vraiment
là de façon si voilà tu as un truc à
faire derrière
ouais c'est vrai ça c'est une tarte oui
j'ai une avant-première à couettes
attend déjà les mêmes lunettes parce que
si j'ai mes choix une terre dont la
finalité est de l'émoi en même temps et
en heure à 2 3 merci colombes et
lunettes cerclées d'or
ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]